la Organización de Estados Americanos
llega a Perú representado por una misión
de alto nivel el organismo intenta
mediar en la crisis política que vive la
nación suramericana su primer día de
trabajo estuvo marcado por la reunión
con el presidente Pedro Castillo así
como con funcionarios de la fiscalía y
el congreso ninguna intención de parte
del
congreso de hacer un golpe
de destapetuosos de la de la de la
Democracia eso fue algo que precisamos
firmemente por su parte el presidente
Castillo señaló según su punto de vista
las causas del problema algunos sectores
Quieren poner en peligro la democracia y
la estabilidad del país con mentiras
para golpear una gestión enfocada en
trabajar por el progreso e igualdad de
todos en este sentido la vicepresidenta
de la nación dime boluarte aseguró que
la democracia en el país estaba en grave
peligro mientras se celebraban los
encuentros manifestantes en favor y en
contra del gobierno protestaron en las
cercanías del congreso
cómo es posible que dentro de nuestro
país tengan que mangonear maltratar la
imagen de un presidente del Perú Perú
pide una crisis política que enfrenta al
poder ejecutivo con el judicial y el
legislativo